today's topic do you ever do you ever
have a hard time uh balancing
balancing spending time with people with
like the online life what do you mean
it's like you know you do this online
work right you're around people all the
time
or you like draw online all the time
right
do you ever get like fatigue of being
around people well yeah that's why i get
out alone that's why i go to bars alone
yeah that's why i go on my way although
i go on bicycle like i go up i got my
alone time i got some times that i don't
spend with nobody because there's always
some people you know even when you're
lonely and people are going to try to
approach me and it's probably one of the
reasons why i look i always meet my
people always talking about yo why you
look so mean well first and foremost i
have a missing [ __ ] face i look mean
and that's the way my face is but no at
the end of the day to answer your
question yeah you have to spend some
time alone because you're always
surrounded that's always connect
connecting with that's why i don't like
taking vacations with people gone it's
it's like
here we are in this place for two weeks
and i'm around you
all day long yeah but that's your that's
like that's like i understand i
understand that that that's a vacation
because some people don't know how to be
in the same space without shutting the
[ __ ] up yes you know what i mean some
people don't have seen face stop being
like yeah always got some [ __ ] yeah you
know what i mean me at me personally
i could be right beside somebody and
they could be reading a book the whole
time and they never gonna feel like
for me
you feel what i'm saying yeah
but bruh
i just can't do it i can't be around
people
i could love the person that could be my
family
we spent three four hours chopping it up
after that don't talk to me
am i weird for that no you're not weird
i sometimes feel like i'm weird
well yeah because it's not it's not
people are not people are not used to
silence
they're very uncomfortable with silence
me my best friends me my best will you
go ahead go ahead
it's not even silence it's like
i'd rather
be on google than talk to you i
understand behold hear me out okay
it is silence go ahead because when
people are uncomfortable uncomfortable
with silence
and they are just they talking not
because they have something to say
but they're talking because they're
trying to fill a gap
if you feel it yeah you you you feel it
it's just
no it's shut the [ __ ] up time yeah
it's weird it's a weird thing because
you can't really put your name like you
can't put your finger on it you can't
believe you put the name on it but there
is such thing as shut the [ __ ] up time
there's some time even when i'm in
vacation with my girl there's sometimes
that you know there's some time that we
pin she does or should i do my [ __ ]
right
she's gonna go back to the room all
right go back to the room cool
you're gonna sit there and have a cigar
at the bar yeah
all right
and that's that and for me i think
that's the logic the longevity of the
thing is she's able to do her [ __ ] i'm
able to do us
she watch her [ __ ] shows that i
don't want to watch you know and
sometimes we're gonna sit on the couch
that's our cue okay we both sit on the
couch right and she watched her [ __ ]
shows and she knows i think your
[ __ ] shows right and i go ugh and i
go ugh
and i go ugh three times i'm off i'm
gonna let you have your time i don't
want the room i'm gonna i don't want to
ruin your [ __ ] i'm not gonna start
roasting your show have your moment i'm
gonna get up go to the office do my
thing or take my bike and go have a ride
i don't want to be that [ __ ] that
complains and an activity you like and i
also don't want to even even i don't
complain okay i've had this happen i
accept to go do an activity that they
want all right but i can't fake i hate
this activity but i'm gonna do it
because they want then i get there and
like you're not having fun i'm like
no i told you i was never gonna have fun
here i'm here because i love you so
much i will spend my time doing [ __ ] i
hate
because it pleases you and i will try
not to look negative while i'm doing it
but i can't fake the fun
the same way you can't fake the funk
listen so i'm there
with a neutral face and you're like
you're not enjoy because i don't fit
your mold the same i would never drag
you girl to go watch this like hour-long
anime series because i know you're gonna
be like why are you watching this
just don't come here it's okay i can
enjoy this by myself what do you wanna
go do go have fun you don't you're
aren't you gonna be mad if you don't no
i don't care go go do what you enjoy i'm
gonna do what i enjoy by myself it's
okay
and when we come together i'll make
dinner for you there'll be food ready
for when you get back don't say [ __ ]
like that no that's true exactly don't
say [ __ ] like that why can't i feel like
that you just don't say [ __ ] like that
can't i see yours if you say [ __ ] like
that you're gonna broadcast it there and
then our [ __ ] inbox we're gonna be
flooded ooh i want a meal by abba
yeah yeah you yup yuck [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you fishing for [ __ ] i think you
know what that's cool you know what it
is you know what it is i think it is you
like to say no to [ __ ] no no you like
to say no to [ __ ] [ __ ] are
gonna be like hey abba you can cook for
me and you're just like swerve
you enjoy that [ __ ] cause every now and
then
in a video you don't fish for [ __ ]
i mean you're gonna fish for fishes
let's call them fishes but you know what
i feel like a jedi i'm bringing bounds
to the force
you know ladies have always been the one
you should get the [ __ ] out but here's
the thing yeah maybe it's because of
like i just think it's nice to cook for
folks
i invite my roommate i feed for uh meat
food for him yeah i like cooking for
people yeah you know absolutely right
and so for me it's just
that's how i show my face i'll do a
little gesture absolutely so i'm just i
was just kidding it's just a frustration
i have and here's another thing it gets
even worse for us
because we do so much social activity
with the online world they're stand-up
now when i get home at the end i'm just
like don't talk to me don't look at me i
don't want to talk about me i do for
work so often when i'm off work i i
listen to people if they wanna talk
but if i have my way i'm by myself and i
do no talking and i'm good with that i
gotta admit a lot of my friends are
complaining that about me what that i
don't talk about me [ __ ] you don't talk
about me you don't share i share all
this [ __ ] listen i don't force you to to
share all this [ __ ] yeah i i'm just very
particular to what i share i don't share
my [ __ ] if you get a glimpse when i'm
ready to share be ready you know what i
mean that's it okay beep game that's
peep game that's the thing do you want
to hear some [ __ ] up you're the person
i talk to or see the most during the
week yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
like i see you two three times a week
for like a few hours because we work
together but that's my whole point is
like when i had a nine or five there
were some colleagues i've seen more than
my wife yeah so people like people take
it personal i'm like this is not you
he's everybody i always say priests
cause work yeah you think we'd be seeing
each other two three times a week of
course not so after i do do this i'm
tapped out [ __ ] you know what i mean
this is this is it
you why don't you talk to myself go on
youtube [ __ ]
everyone preach i talk about myself too
much for my taste that's why i don't do
podcasts that's why i don't do a bunch
of stuff i've heard my voice so much i'm
like [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up have you
ever looked in the mirror and told
yourself to shut the [ __ ] up so i'm just
ugh
so you were saying about it every time
every time every time i rewatch a video
i said to myself shut the [ __ ] up every
time i rewatch video because i don't
watch i watch these videos the same time
as you watch these videos okay he does
the editing we have the junior editor or
whatever
and he releases him release and then i
watch and then and then i watch him and
i say well so when i said comment and
they said like yo priest shut the [ __ ]
up more he's annoying and i'm like same
[ __ ] same i think i'm annoying too you
know
[Laughter]
i've been there
yeah same i mean yeah you're not wrong
[Laughter]
[Music]
same i think it's annoying too but he's
me i can't escape this okay i can't
escape this i'm stuck okay
gotta deal with this [ __ ] but anyways
all that to say i need to shut the [ __ ]
up sometimes and you know we did it this
whole last video about you know what is
the best advice that you would say to
marry people and i said shut the [ __ ] up
it was for both there's a lot of people
that took it wrong i was like well it's
for men too and i was like
yes
yes it's mostly us i'm gonna tell you
that i'm more willing to do a [ __ ]
uh activity with my girl
that i don't i'm not uh i'm not it's not
my best activity i wouldn't do that then
she is willing to do a [ __ ] activity
because my [ __ ] threshold is bigger
than hers i can accept a lot of more
[ __ ] than she can accept so i will
do activities that you want to go do
this
not really but sure let's go
because to me is
how often are you asking her to do your
[ __ ] activities never
yes nobody comments
hold on hold on because in 22 years
we've established the [ __ ] meter
but do you even want to that badly no i
don't because she's not going to enjoy
it but me
because i function differently you
understand what i'm saying if like if
it's slightly [ __ ] she's going to be
like yo you want to do this i'm like
yeah sure let's go i mean you already
know that i'm a yeah sure kind of guy
right so i'm gonna go i'm not gonna give
you the most fun but i'm gonna be there
with my girl i work a lot at least you
know i'm gonna see her there right it's
gonna be that so so i'm gonna focus not
on the activity i'm gonna focus on the
person right understand what i'm saying
so that's why i did something but she
don't ask me to do [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that she knows listen i'm
gonna do this and that and that uh you
good yeah i'm good all right she asked
to be polite my girl is polite i'm more
on the logic side if you i know you're
not gonna enjoy it i'm not gonna ask you
to go there and i got one my best friend
shout out to you you know who you are
right now he's in the states he's not
even out here he's in the states he's
been in the states for like the past
three years or some [ __ ] like that and
three four years even god damn it's been
long and i see him last time i seen the
[ __ ] was two years ago two years
and a half ago see him sometimes we
don't talk
i go to the bar we eat we chitchat and
then after that we're gonna be two hours
looking at a screen in front of us and
just chuckling because we got the same
kind of sense of humor yeah we're going
to be chuckling side eyes and that's it
we don't need to talk it up we don't
need to are you guys all right yeah we
good
all right
and the most
interaction we're gonna have is with the
rape waiter serving us drinks cause
sometimes you don't you don't have to
say [ __ ] don't talk you see me in public
yeah i just sit in the corner yeah
don't talk to nobody knowing a mingle
and then you know you haven't seen me in
public because coveting [ __ ] but i
started to do that more and more i don't
want to talk to no one and you know it
gets worse i think also dude like i
think my personal life takes a hit a
little bit in terms of dating but like
yo what my personal life takes a hit in
terms of dating because i'm so busy with
this work and this work is every day
there is no days off and the hours are
inconsistent and you know one thing
that's been doing this [ __ ]
going to text me at five eight in the
morning six there's not a consistent way
yeah yeah yeah yeah cause that's just
kind of the way the work works it
functions this way at the moment
especially and i don't think it's ever
gonna change i think you can organize
things
you can you can you can organize the
chaos a little bit to have a little bit
more
functionality to it okay but it's
interesting to me because sometimes i
ask people and they're like yeah okay
what are you doing this weekend i'm like
cool i'm free this weekend like all
right but i'm like i'm working during
saturday during the day for three four
hours and then same thing sunday
like do you work every day i'm like yeah
um and i could see they're visibly like
healed by it but i'm like miss how do
you think you get like this level of
success do you think it's a regular nine
to five like do you think this is a
regular job kind of thing right i mean
and i think a lot of people don't
recognize that even though they see
folks through a screen or they see
people at high levels of success or
whatever it may be they don't recognize
the kind of hours that need to go in
order to maintain that or to keep that
functioning and so again this kind of
speaks to the other thing where it's
like the idea of it is way more
appealing than the reality of it if you
want quality time with a full weekend
where nobody's looking at their phone
the whole time
you don't want to date somebody who does
what i do no you don't you don't you
want maybe maybe you want what comes
with it yeah maybe you want the the the
pluses yeah but you don't want that you
don't
and and that's something that i'm having
to reckon with because i'm having to
have conversations with people being
like this is my life i'm okay with it
i got a sense of balancing it's all
right but if it's not for you or you're
not happy that's okay too i got a rule
in my house that i set myself for and
that's just for that and it's gonna go
on if i have kids and [ __ ] like that
when we when i eat i take off the watch
i take off good you know i take the
watch off i agree everything i put on
the side we eat when we eat we eat just
yeah i mean touch that call so but
a whole weekend
even when we go on vacay i still gotta
stay connected because we don't know
listen the reason why i'm on this vacay
is because of what i do for work so i
got to stay connected so you got to take
you know you got to give and take but
come back to the place where you
wouldn't want to talk to [ __ ] i
was chuckling because i feel like i've
experienced that
when we went to l.a when we went to the
states because
i got off the plane
then i met you with whatever the [ __ ]
you was at we did whatever the [ __ ] we
had to do we had like two podcasts to do
then
so that was business
and then we went to the airbnb and what
happened you went to your room i went to
my room and i saw you the next morning
yeah that's it we don't yes sir
yo what do you wanna do you wanna do
this yeah cool you got up you went to
the the kitchen you did your [ __ ] i
stayed in my room yeah
and then after that
you know what
there was never a time when i'm like why
didn't me and prison do more
that never crossed my mind i'm good this
is how that's good yeah do some
activities yeah we went
uh the the the kind of uh japanese
japanese yeah fake japanese [ __ ] yeah
yeah the americana
japanese [ __ ] we went to eat there
i don't think one word was spoken
i said oh this black chicken looks weird
yes
like that's weird when i have a bite i'm
like oh i'm not sure okay let me see
and i got that and someone told me this
the old days she's like albert you know
what you got
you 31 but you got old [ __ ] energy and
i said yes yeah
yeah do you want to go camping
no but do i want to go sit on a park
bench and just stare at people while i
judge them yes have a cigar and whiskey
yes yes and quiet too yeah yes yeah
that's good that's dope so you know i i
i question myself sometimes but i'm like
i enjoy this life but you know what the
thing is it's good to question yourself
it's good to be like okay well you know
it's kind of weird whatever it's good to
see
it's good that it's good that you do
that
but i can't do a whole day with somebody
yo i can't do like multiple days with
people like i just can't do it
i love my roommate my roommate's the
best i've had the same roommate for six
years we've been in the same apartment
for six years and i've never thought of
moving north i ever thought like i need
some privacy
this [ __ ] stays in history yeah yeah
yeah i stay in my view when we see each
other it's cool you want dinner i made
food i look out for you look out for me
and that's it let's be honest what let's
be honest what's up you see me more than
you see your roommate
you see me more than you see the [ __ ]
that lives here yes that's so true
it is perfect we respect the cleaning i
just
i don't know maybe i'm uh maybe we're
broken i don't know but no no i'm good
with it does it work
does that system work yes if you reverse
it
what do you mean if you reverse it
like if you flip it and reverse it
put that thing down
right there
is it working is it is you haven't been
in that yet
is it working good was it worth it
open that flip down
dig down that let me reverse it i don't
know why
why because you work yeah
it's my fault it's my fault this is the
person i spent the most time with on a
week-to-week basis
i [ __ ] his mind working yeah
is it worth it
lee now you're doomed because every time
something sounds like like a song you
won't be able to sing it it's crazy it's
great though that that's yours i give
you full credit for that but anyways i
don't know this is just a random chit
chat uh let us know what you guys think
in the comments below do you relate to
any of this do you guys feel the same
way if so let us know what you guys
think if you liked today's video leave a
like okay it helps out with the
algorithm all that good stuff so if
you're liking this kind of chat this
type of content let us know yo patrice
o'neill said it the best yes i want you
there
yeah no listen man we we we don't want
to be alone
but we want to be by ourselves
meaning
[Laughter]
now i want you in the abode in the house
yeah but not right next to me yo go
check that skit that skin
is a hundred yeah yeah yeah yeah
what's your name wouldn't it be more
nice put your aim around me yo he she
knocked it down to the feet
let us know what you guys think
[Music]
foreign